et puis une nouvelle la nouvelle
convention des médecins après la
polémique suscitée récemment entre les
pouvoirs publics et le principal
syndicat des médecins c'est à dire la
csmf
on attendait de connaître le choix des
principaux intéressés c'est à dire il
s'agissait de savoir combien de médecins
allait s'orienter vers les tarifs libres
et bien à ces chiffres viennent de
sortir
sur l'ensemble de la france 5,75 pour
cent des médecins seulement refuse les
tarifs conventionnés mais les inégalités
d'une région à l'autre vont poser un
nouveau problème les chiffres totaux à
cet égard non pas une signification très
explicite ce qu'il faut considérer c'est
ce qui se passe région par région mais
pour bien figurer les choses disons que
france entière
un médecin sur cinq désormais aura la
liberté de ses tarifs mais par exemple
dans la région rhône alpes ce sera un
médecin sur quatre tueur à la liberté
des tarifs dans l'île de france a des
région parisienne ça sera un médecin sur
trois est à paris ville - d'un médecin
sur deux respectera le tarif
conventionnel ça signifie qu'il y aura
des régions avec des médecins cher et
des régions avec des médecins de rien il
y aura des régions comme paris ville où
il deviendra où il y aura de très
sérieux problèmes pour accéder
dans tous les secteurs de la médecine à
des médecins pratiquant les tarifs
conventionnels
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire vos
syndicats vous allez continuer à vous
opposer à ce système qui se met en place
nous voudrions si vous continuez à
contester cette convention que nous
considérons être une fausse convention
par rapport aux systèmes intérieurs et
nous allons faire tout notre possible
pour convaincre nos interlocuteurs de
modifier à ce avant le dispositif du
contrat actuel de façon à enrayer ces
effets négatifs
de la convention qui vient d'être
adoptée cela dit tout dépend de la
politique générale pendant tant d un
point de vue de la santé si on entend
revenir de la solidarité nationale à un
système d'assurance banal effectivement
le processus actuellement aucun chez
parfaitement cohérent